I have visual ownership this is  organized crime Mexico narco traffickers  called Toto ABBA the cocaine of the sea  the fishing of the Taba by Chinese  traffickers and Mexican cartels is  killing of Akita the vaquita is getting  extinct there were 100 and then there  were 60 and now there's fewer than 30 to  stop the killing of the vaquita we have  to take down those traffickers the whole  thing stinks it is corruption all the  way who is a chap all of it the drama  there's some really bad guys here they  don't want to see us succeed  if we don't say the vaquita we will lose  the most beautiful places on the planet  I keep thinking about the moment when  only one Akita would be left in the wild  this is the war against the extinction  of a species we have to hold on to the  hope that it's gonna work the poachers  are unacceptable  there take any means necessary  clock's ticking we will fight for every  single life we won't stop  [Music]  [Music]